urlaub in corona zeiten die meisten
deutschen bleiben im land nur zwei
prozent wollen außerhalb europas ferien
machen so viele einschränkungen zu hohes
risiko in die quarantäne falle zu
beraten
doch egal wo urlaub 2020 wird
unvergesslich bleiben gesperrte strände
mindestabstand und masken pflicht auch
im flieger einheitliche chor ohne regeln
in deutschland fehlanzeige
in mecklenburg vorpommern sind
tagesausflüge nur mit unterkunft möglich
macht es das sinn überhaupt in den
urlaub zu fahren und sollte die
urlaubskasse nicht der deutschen
tourismus und gastronomie branche helfen
urlaub 2020 wir werden uns alle daran
erinnern ganz sicher mit einer großen
frage zurück zur neuen normalität
vielleicht navi hat was geplant patricia
beziehen
ich war das abgesagt ich mache überhaupt
nichts ich kann es auch gar nicht wo der
schnee in uns zu hören ach ich wollte in
ein familienhotel mit meinen ganzen wenn
man weiß wenn man mehrere kinder hat
weiß man einfach urlaub ist nur alltag
unter erschwerten bedingungen insofern
ist für mich urlaub nicht so wahnsinnig
wichtig aber ich muss dazu sagen ich
kann es tatsächlich schwer
nachvollziehen dass wir mitten in dieser
pandemie wo immer noch also nicht nur
die gesundheit von vielen menschen auf
dem spiel steht sondern auch die
existenzen von vielen menschen dass wir
uns so wahnsinnig viel um diese urlaubs
frage drehen es erscheint mir dann
wirklich ganz banal also ich werde mein
mann hat einfach verbringen mit ein paar
ausflügen ich will aufs fahrrad steigen
ein bisschen herum fahren
den leuten absagen würde oder abbrechen
würde wenn eine vollmacht kriegen du
siehst du was da los ist teilweise
richtig und das finde ich ist der grund
gemeinheit ich meinen die gang ordner
waren und so weiter irgendwo kommt es ja
auch alles sehr ich glaube wir müssen
jetzt mal alle mal kurz raus aber
natürlich nur unter den vorgegebenen
bedingungen das ist gar nicht so einfach
im moment ich weiß nicht wie es euch
geht aber ich empfinde so eine große
verunsicherung diesbezüglich also was
darf man was kann man es ist in der tat
auch eine geldfrage es kommt ja immer
darauf an wie man so konzentriert ist
aber ich wollte jetzt zum beispiel mit
meinen sechs schwestern in meiner mama
okay dann habe ich gedacht ja klar
deutschland macht sinn lasst uns hier
bleiben dann habe ich mal an der ostsee
angerufen also die preise ld die können
wir uns nicht erlauben also dass das war
teilweise doppelt so teuer als wenn man
ins ausland fliegt und deswegen sage ich
glaube ich
auch etwas was viele nachvollziehen
können dass das immer auch noch eine
luxus debatte ist also ich kann das
natürlich verstehen das ist für ganz
viele gerade primär ist und dass dadurch
auch so eindruck entsteht wie du fährst
ich in urlaub und warum nicht und wenn
du wohin aber viele menschen die sich
zum beispiel auch im vorfeld vorkommen
urlaube gar nicht leisten konnten für
die ändert sich eh nicht viel
und da glaube ich auch kommt so eine
letztlich schon diese schere auch
sichtbar
aber das war ja schon immer ein luxus
themen oder verwandten ab an sich na ja
es gab zumindest immer einen relativ
großen teil das waren so ein viertel bis
ein fünftel der bevölkerung die nie in
urlaub fahren kunden weil sie einfach zu
wenig verdienen und das finde ich in
einem land das so reich ist wie in
deutschland
schon schlimm also man kann sagen urlaub
ist luxus aber eigentlich braucht doch
jeder mensch mal dass er weg kommt und
vor allen dingen auch für die kinder
ich meine die ganz klassenkameraden die
fahnen weg und erzählen dann oder posten
dann irgendwann ihre tollen
urlaubsbilder und dann gibt's halt
kinder die kommen nie weg und dieses
jahr finde ich oder erwarte ich ist es
natürlich viel schlimmer also im
frühjahr haben natürlich viele leute
viel weniger einkommen gehabt als normal
die jetzt kurzarbeit haben oder die
selbstständig sind freiberufler den ist
alles weggebrochen und ich finde da
hätte man politisch auch mehr machen
können was vielleicht nicht ganz den
urlaub aber man kann zum beispiel durch
rechnen wir denken ja jetzt die
mehrwertsteuer das ist richtig teuer das
wird bei den meisten leuten gar nicht
ankommen
20 milliarden von dem gleichen geld
hätte man jeder zweiten familie in
deutschland also jedem zweiten haushalt
1000 euro geben können die man dann
gezielt entweder in hotels im inland
oder in restaurants oder eben innenstadt
einzelhandel mehrwertsteuer irgendwie im
größten umsatz seit 26 jahren im mai
gebaut ist es fruchtet ja auch dann
vielleicht auf andere art und weise dann
für die geschäfte die wieder heile heile
können ja auch also viele neben
natürlich die senkung der bekommen die
mehrheit steuersenkungen gar nicht weil
das die unternehmen einen kassieren also
zum beispiel ein anbieter wie amazon
der hat zwar jetzt e mail verschickt
dann würde die weitergeben aber ich weiß
eine kollegin von mir die hat einfach
mal die preise verglichen vorher nachher
es hat sich nichts geändert vieles ist
sogar teurer geworden das heißt da
sacken unternehmen unser steuergeld
die also in deutschland kaum steuern
zahlen und ist eigentlich überhaupt
nicht nötig habe warnt ich verdiene da
bin ich ja sogar nein ich fange ich mal
was amazon und starbucks angeht dass die
menschen ihr geld generieren oder die
firma institution hier getrickst auch
die steuern zu zahlen haben und dass die
senkung der mehrwertsteuer keinen sinn
macht beim endverbraucher sich nichts
ändert absolut versuchen auch so ein
bisschen genau dabei zu bleiben dass man
sich als auch wieder in verschiedenen
zeitung auch nichts dass zum beispiel
bestimmte urlauber die dann in
norddeutschland urlaub machen aber
zurückgeschickt werden pro forma weil
sie als gütersloh kommt zum beispiel das
ging ja jetzt auch die letzten tage
durch die presse ist das nicht in
ordnung findet ihr das okay dass man
einfach so ein abwasch macht das ist ja
schon wieder ein anderes thema weil da
geht es ja um die stigmatisierung
letztlich naja aber die am urlaub
gemacht und darum geht es ja dass das
ist er an genau das was die
verunsicherung ja auch ganz klar
platziert dass man überhaupt nicht mehr
weiß wohin verreisen darf ich überhaupt
verreisen gibt es den lokalen schotter
und oder nicht darf ich ins ausland das
ist es anders und es ist definitiv jahre
regeln geben also nicht dass jemand
losfährt und weiß gar nichts davon da
wird er zurück geschickt und ich finde
auch viele regeln sehr unlogisch also
zum beispiel sagen wir ja die gastwirte
die müssen die tische ganz weit
auseinander stellen die flieger buchen
sich voll also da sitzt einer neben dem
anderen und ich also das kann mir keiner
erklären dass das also weniger
gefährlich ist in zwei stunden flug oder
auch nur eine stunde direkt
nebeneinander wo die leute dann
mindestens wenn das getränk serviert
wird alle die masken absetzen oder
jemand der eben meinetwegen im
biergarten oder auch drinnen im lokal
vans fenster offen ist die tische etwas
enger beieinander hat damit er irgendwie
wieder auf seinen umsatz kommt also das
ist auch unlogisch und ich glaube also
das werfe ich auch denen vor die solche
entscheidung treffen
die leute nehmen natürlich irgendwann
die maßnahmen die ich mir ernst wenn sie
das gefühl haben das ist alles völlig
inkonsistent in den einzelnen
bundesländern wird es ganz
unterschiedlich gehandhabt und das ist
dann auch nicht verantwortungsvoll weil
aber ich glaube das macht man nicht weil
es nicht verantwortungsvolle sondern die
frage ist ja was anstelle dessen bzw
welches andere land bekommt das besser
hin und ich finde das ganz wichtig auch
noch einmal darauf hinzuweisen dass
deutschland ja im verhältnis zu vielen
anderen ländern uns sehr gut durch die
krise gebracht hat ich meine die
tatsache dass in den usa 125 1000
menschen an cholera gestorben sind und
sich täglich 100.000 anstecken heißt für
mich ganz persönlich dass selbst wenn
ich nicht jede entscheidung gleich
nachvollziehen kann oder wenn eine dich
sogar erweist auch das ist ja teil von
politik untersagt soweit dazu dass man
das eben vorher nicht immer sagen kann
finde ich trotzdem dass man noch ganz
gut arbeiten rankweil sind wir durch die
krise besser gekommen als andere länder
und vor allen dingen besser als so
länder wie großbritannien oder die usa
wie alt regierungschefs haben die
eigentlich so das gefühl hatten also das
ignorieren wir mal eben das thema also
das war frage zum schluss wo fahren sie
hin wissen sie schon oder fein so
überhaupt weg doktor wir fahren also wir
fahren nach frankreich und haben einen
ferienhaus also ich gebe zu ich würde
jetzt nicht im hotel fahren ich hätte
einfach viel zu viel angst wenn dann
einmal aussagen
wir fahren also bringt eben im auto weil
ich auch fliegen zurzeit nicht so
richtig attraktiv
ehrlich gesagt und dann wirklich auch
wenn auch ein bisschen ängstlich
vielleicht auch mal meinem mann ein
bisschen älter und ist und deswegen
haben wir jetzt gesagt aber die reise
die können wir uns und ich glaube viele
menschen haben schon das bedürfnis
gerade nach diesem frühjahr jetzt auch
mal was anderes sehen muss einen
leichten tapetenwechsel
[Musik]